ciao ragazzi per quanto mi sembra
assurdo questo qui un video che mi state
chiedendo da un po di tempo ossia farvi
vedere che cosa c'è nella mia libreria
vi dico subito che ho leggermente
sistemato quello che avevo la sopra
perché era un pochino più confusionario
quindi quello che vedrete che già in
bella mary e il risultato già di qualche
minuto di lavoro nel cercare di
riorganizzare ora questa è la mia
libreria realtà c'è altra roba attorno
nella quale tengo libri che vi mostrerò
sappiate che non pensavo che una
libreria potesse raccontare così tanto
di una persona e delle sue turbe
psichiche quindi bando alle ciance non
so quanto durerà questo video molto
probabilmente sarà un video più lungo
del solito perché ci sono delle cose che
necessitano un minimo di spiegazione
sperano che possa interessarmi sono
persona la quale piace molto leggere
alla quale piace immensamente
collezionare libri appena preso casa ho
pensato subito che una parete avesse
come minimo andare a una libreria mi
trovo molto belli da vedere
fanno un sacco di arredamento li amo amo
le storie quindi questa qui è la parete
che ho destinato a questa libreria che è
ikea cento per cento quella lì bianca
dove in realtà seta bideri ci stanno
tutti quanti i buchini per scegliere
all'altezza degli scaffali confido in un
futuro quando avrò una casa ancora più
bella di poterne fare una propria di
quelle fatte a mano da geppetto per il
momento non contento di questa bando le
ciance partiamo subito con il pool m
libreria non ha un senso logico o almeno
ce l'ha in alcuni punti in altri
scordatevelo ghiaccio subito vedere ho
un po paura
lascia
ciaccia casa
[Musica]
non di chi marca insomma sembra che una
canzone di quelle di mezzi e giapponesi
mette cinesi per fare le presentazioni
partiamo da qui questo qui è il mio
reparto legato a sceneggiatura scrittura
e recitazione sono tutti quanti dei
libri che in passato ho letto che
possono essere lo so questo che se ormai
la biglia di qualsiasi sceneggiatore
scrittore storiche roberto vacca stephen
king on racing razze sco bellissimi
missino questo che mi venne regalato da
un mio collega attore mentre stava
lavorando a un film
roba che fondamentalmente tengo tutta
quanta 15enne passiamo in quello che io
definisco 1 gli scaffali spazzatura cioè
sono tutti quanti libri belli chi mi
piacciono ma che ho buttato
assolutamente senza senso tra questi
vorrei scusate ci sta anche new ricami
meraviglioso per questo vorrei
assolutamente citare non è la rosa
carino sono messo però valutato
recitarvi anche orgoglio e pregiudizio
la mia storia d'amore preferita in
assoluto forse seconda solo a cimentare
stosa che altro abbiamo cecità
bellissimo questo scaffale non ha
bisogno di presentazioni ci stanno tutti
e sette ieri potere in italiano il
signore degli anelli o signora bugarin
perché non lo so le cronache di
terramare e la trilogia di bartimeus
quindi stiamo parlando di fantasy
specialmente come si sono piaciuti in
italiano personalmente leggo pochissimi
si nissim e fantasy in italiano perché
voglio fare la fila non perché sono
scritti in inglese con la fortuna di
poterlo capire e quindi è raro che io
tenga i libri che non siano in lingua
originale almeno tutti quelli che vedete
che non sono in in originali sono vecchi
e per vecchi intendo di almeno sette
anni fa ti voglio harry potter soldi
tanto tempo fa scendiamo giù che cos'è
quello un altro scaffale spazzatura il
decameron bellissimo conversazione in
sicilia stupendo che cosa abbiamo
quindi domani ti c'è stato un periodo in
cui ho amato ammaniti alla follia alla
ragazza di bube altro capolavoro guida
galattica per autostoppisti non sono mai
riuscito a leggere lo iniziò velo fermo
sempre pur esistendo un sacco di cose mi
dicono che stupendo raga non ce la
faccio a questo è chiarissimo come
libero tavole però piombini molto
stanchi e un libro geniale esempio il
nazareno c'era un bambino che divento
grande ma vecchio no fine perché è
uscito questo tra tutti segni dall'alto
quest'anno facciamo le 33 anni quindi
per acciona domanda nella risposta solo
a bellissimo questo qui alcuni gli
scaffali della mia libreria sono per i
manga io sono un fan non tanto le manda
ma di alcune storie in particolare qui
abbiamo il mio manga preferito in
assoluto che un giorno di questi dovrà
ritornare a rileggere che ram ragazzino
malato malato malato malato malato di
ram
secondo me continua a essere un fumetto
geniale e sono un fan grandissimo del
lavoro di rumiko takahashi che l'autrice
è un fan anche se escludo un pochino
lamu non mi fa impazzire solo fa
puliamo anche un posto schifo sono fan
sfegatato anche di tre yart che alcune
di voi conoscono come una porta
socchiusa ai confini del sole le clamp
che sono il gruppo di mangaka si dice
non lo so che lo ha creato sono senoner
geniali di pinè delle storie abbastanza
paese ha un posto ci stanno pure delle
cose che non mi tornano dico solo che se
non sbaglio all'interno di questo vi
faccio vedere un altro loro lavoro anche
al cup sakura bellissimo anche questo
stupendo la carta del tempo all'interno
di questo ci sta non lo so pure una roba
per cui una bambina delle elementari
barra medie si fidanza con il suo
professore ma non voglio andare ad
indagare troppo
leggo e vado avanti senza cercare di
farmi troppe domanda ecco più avanti
questo è un altro scaffali diciamo
spazzatura in realtà è uno scaffale alto
quindi ci sono un sacco di libri ati e
sono anche legati molto a film come
potete
15 affari notti che mi è stato regalato
un dizionario di tutti i film molto
bello i grandi film anche qui cioè
dovrebbe sembrare in 3d sono che potete
vederlo benissimo bellissimo perché
raramente santo che anzi lo rifiuto che
grazie a queste qui è un regalo che mi
viene fatto da nei miei amichetti il mio
compleanno e sono tutti quanti poster di
film science fiction dell'iss bellissimo
un regalo stupendo horror sono libri
stupendi e infine ex perché veramente
scusate sono malato di queste cose ne
trovo molto belle note ci sta cinzia chi
ama rat man sa di cosa sto pensando
questo qui è una si chiama graphic novel
graphic novel geniale insieme a questo
scusate solamente questo primo volume
sky gol meraviglioso perché se non
sbaglio disegni mi ricordano molto
quelli delle winx
io trovo molto belli che siano sbagliati
disegnatore ha contribuito o poi dovrà
finire perché una saga superfiga tutto
questa portata e prima non vi ho detto
non perché non lo so ho celozzi cielo a
cascetta questo qui è un regalo di
lucoli e il premio che è albatros mi
viene dato a questo cliente il mio
scaffale i dizionari inglese zingarelli
tedesco ce n'è un altro lì che mi è
stato dato il grammatica italiana latino
greco sarà una festa alla sopra perché
non uso mai questo qui bellissimo libro
il novecento letterario qui dal
novecento stupendo queste qui mi venne
regalato da una ragazza in un periodo in
cui non ho ancora fatto coming out senza
che fosse situato stare nella castità
cinema sta malissimo l'illuminista
questi tre libri mi secca qui questo
chiede un secondo di chiacchiera chi ne
ha avvicinato alla lettura è stata mia
nonna anche a volte ne avete visto nelle
live comunque in generale nelle stories
e questi sono i primi libri che mi fece
leggere sono una raccolta di racconti il
castello di ghiaccio tempesta e mollica
e altri racconti
una roba stupenda che le ho chiesto di
potermi prendere
perché mi ricorda da dove è nato tutto
il mio amore per i libri sono
vecchissimi sono forse la cosa più
importante da mettere questa libreria
scendo giù qua abbiamo le moleskine a
tutte quante le agende anche io ho usato
nel corso degli anni che i cani che vi
farò vedere più tardi un regalo di lui
per natale con cui mi tengo ancora
coerente stupendo scaffale spazzatura ma
questo è diverso all'interno di questo
scaffale ci stanno delle cose molto
molto importante che in particolare una
tralasciando il fatto che il caso vuole
che sia un pochino uno scaffale dark
come potete vedere da faletti aita
incubo il nome del male ci stanno un
pochino di libri che sono tra il
thriller all'horror parlerà di loro ci
sta lei che mi è stato regalato ad
alcuni miei amici in questa di molto
carini mi hanno fatto come regalo
assolutamente così perché gli faceva
piacere dei miei cari amici quindi non
sono alcuni a caso e poi c'è lui in ii
per lui per chi non lo conoscesse questo
qui a roma non mi ricordo a quale
cultura appartiene esattamente ma come
potete vedere a un occhio solo un po
fuoco a un occhio solo un occhio che io
disegnato io la leggenda vorrebbe che
esprime un desiderio venti disegni un
occhio solo e quando il desiderio si
avvera disegni l'altro occhio questo che
mi è stato regalato da un ragazzo da un
ragazzo mi ricordo bene io l'ho espresso
un desiderio non credo tre anni fa un
furgone di manco l'occhio ma conto
presto di riempirlo altro scappare un po
spazzatura se non fosse per loro che mi
vennero regalati alla pixar lo vedete up
ratatouille e buon lì dietro di loro ci
stanno un po di qua già qualche fantasia
ancora vecchio terry brooks sparisce
amara o ken follett stupendo che dico
questo no pazzesco scriptorium mirabilia
scendiamo giù sbam
allora qui un momento se la uno scaffale
di manga è un pochino più ragazza
gioiello questo qui invece un pochino
più da ragazzo che si ricorda di avere
un cadrà con bolla tutto quanto in giù
stato che non tirerò fuori mine che è
meraviglioso e un altro manga che senza
i al cavaliere l'uso dei rozzi e in iale
roba geniale primo scaffale di giochi da
tavolo abbiamo curio che mi è stato
regalato da asm utili la casa che fa
anche exploding kittens e soprattutto
uno dei giochi preferiti che è ora che
lo faccia scusate dixit li ringrazierò
sempre a smooth i primi mandato tutte
quante le espansioni se volete vederne
altre le aspetto due titoli che secondo
me sono assolutamente validi ragazzi che
oltre a dixit dovete assolutamente
comprare non esiste avalon
se vi piace il lupus in tabula come il
gioco questo qui è veramente non sto
scherzando
non scherzo centomila volte meglio avano
una cacca in testa a lupus in tabula
come un elefante cache in testa non ci
quando cioè è stupendo stupendo sempre
di asm od in un'altra opera d'arte
personalmente che è nome in codice è
difficile da spiegare ma facilissimo da
giocare è una di quelle cose che devi
fare per poterla capire è un geniale
geniale infatti ha vinto un premio
vederlo spirit esiliare gioco dell'anno
in tedesco 2016 bellissimo là sopra
quelli li ritengo perché mi ricordano
no è una collezione di libri legati
pittori vedo jean roy a tiziano
qualsiasi cosa 80 essere bellissimi e
stupendamente colorati sono anche un
ricordo unico questo aspettate il bello
di zoom un attimo proprio scaffale della
miseria non perché ci siano dei titoli
sbagliati ma perché ovviamente non c'è
senso alcuno credo forse che siano tre
pochi libri che credo manco di aver
letto del tutto abbiamo dell'anno zero
calcare non aspettano la rimangio carino
paolo sorrentino tutti hanno ragione
bello anche voi lo fa farò il finissimo
scritto col mio sangue stupendo adc
nutrivano l'operaio stube ragazzi forse
no che lo stesso non belli e quelli di o
in quello di quando ero degano ci stanno
un sacco di ricette cucinati da molto
interessante del consiglio in generale
anche se non siete più vegani perché vi
permettono veramente di allargare un
pochino all'orizzonte mentale che
abbiamo del se non mangi la carne o se
non mangi determinate sostanze che
provengono gli animali automaticamente i
per forza mangiare di meno per quanto
riguarda questo ragionamento se seguite
cucina il botanica vi rendete conto che
non è così passiamo ora a il reparto
inglese della mia libreria va regalo del
mio primo ragazzo cofanetto di twilight
me lo lessi tutto lo trovo a bo mi no
questo che invece mi è piaciuto neil
gaiman in generale io amo come scrive
anche se a volte restare solo un pochino
banali non sono delle belle idee che lì
non mi piace come sviluppa cudin chi
essi so perché lo staff a vedere la
ladra di libri io non ce la faccio a
leggerlo ho fatto una chiacchiera
infinita come una ragazza e continua
spingermi a leggerlo non ce la faccio
non ce la faccio loro meraviglioso unico
stupendo grazie george martin grazie
magari se ti sbrighi anche a fare gli
ultimi a migliorarli visto che come
finita serie fa cagare a bellissimo
dovuto del file signore le mosche un
viaggio comunque meno fare cassa un bar
di sopra che abbiamo al sen
benissimo quello che è sotto poi il
prossimo scaffale faccio un piccolo
cappello introduttivo stiamo parlando il
mio scaffali preferite in assoluto lo
scaffale degli harry potter
allora questi sono quelli in inglese
anche io ho letto e riletto e stretto
qua sono sbagli lioce esatto cioè che
l'ultima cosa da trieste a tra l'avevano
fatto la trovate in giapponese nella sua
presa perché mi piaceva quattro
bellissime del giapponese a che altro ci
stanno alzino volta mi sono parla pure
quelli in americano così poi a maze
runner questo qui a e anche james belli
belli belli come liberi mette il milan
lo so ci andiamo giù con questa qui
un'altra serie molto carina mi è
piaciuto nella stessa scrittrice della
ragazza del treno bellissimo e per
questi vi chiedo un secondo permettetemi
di presentarvi il mio autore di fantasy
preferito in assoluto particolare per
queste due serie
sto parlando di jonathan stroud che ha
fatto la serie di locke denko ed è lui a
una penna che secondo me è livina una
capacità di mettere in piedi delle
storie che sono stupende dei personaggi
che sono complessi pierre bellissimi e
porta e suggerisce anche delle
ambientazioni meravigliose si parla
sempre di londra e distopiche questa è
una serie detta così può sembrare banale
su dei fantasmi non è così semplice
el'altro che lui e bartimeus un altro
capolavoro per me sono libri io ormai
vado a stelle e 5 il massimo uno vuol
dire faceva meglio a pulirti circuito le
pagine bianche di un manoscritto poi
abbiamo un libro dicevo prima è il mio
libro preferito d'amore cime tempestose
emily bronte cosa mi ha tirato fuori e
poi c'è lui forse la serie più brutta
che abbia mai letto e abbandonato percy
jackson
il cofanetto lo trovo meraviglioso a
percy jackson è uno dei libri più
sopravvalutati della storia dei libri
che esistano c'è una persona che mi
mette una dopo l'altra delle vicende
mitologiche ai quali in realtà non
aggiunge nessun twist se non un pochino
modificarle modificarle nel senso che le
modernizza ma poi le risolve esattamente
come nel mito quindi io che ho fatto il
classico so esattamente che alla fine
quando tu venissi nel posto pieno di
stato e c'è medusa tu con lo specchio
riuscirai a non farti prendere da medusa
ok una volta va bene dopo che diventa
una serie di vicende che non porta
niente non evolve la trama non la
costruisce ma a un certo punto decide di
interrompere per farti arrivare al
finale
no io mi sento preso per il culo
sinceramente al cofanetto meraviglioso
sempre su questo scaffale abbiamo il
nino autore di libri per bambini
preferito roal dahl un dio ragazzi credo
di non dire niente di nuovo lui è un dio
e poi il primo fantasy che abbiamo amato
limite nero si chiama tipo vampiretto o
vampirello me lo regalò una mimica e
italiano insieme ad altri temi che se
mangio il mio cane o bellissimo
bellissimo risale al 26 11 2013 cioè io
facevo non lo voglio sapere quanti anni
è infine proprio signori sono le favole
tesoro non so se vedete la bellezza di
questo libro credo di averlo comprato a
londra quando la prete no party alle
pagine d'oro cioè impaginato ea delle
illustrazioni un po anticate mi fa
impazzire tetto finisce del cane la sua
ombra non è bellissimo è bellissimo l'ho
già detto che bellissimo qui è
bellissimo qua si diventa nerd questa
qui è la quinta edizione di run jensen
devono sono un grandissimo appassionato
di di andy ho amato da 3.5 ma la quinta
secondo me fa un salto avanti con questo
libro che è una espansione di di andy e
potete vedere qua scusate con la quarta
replica appartiene al mondo magic un
gioco di carte che magari qualcuno
lo hanno fatto anche di manuali sto
facendo il master per una avventura con
degli amici
ambientata proprio su replica e loro mi
hanno regalato ma anche questo libro è
una raccolta anche di disegni at work in
generale molto molto bello lo uso una
respirazione che porta al contenuto di
questo sacchetto questo sacchetto
contiene dei dati anche un altro gruppo
di dean di composto da alcuni amici che
forse conoscete claudio di viaggio marco
giorni della slingbox benedetta della
studentessa adriano della sindone ha
regalato scusate il mio 7 gradi con i
quali gli faccio alcuni a lance max
numeri in in questo scaffale degni di
nota sono anche tutti questi libri che
sono di grammatica inglese in
particolare a collins molto bello ma lui
è un dizionario meraviglioso se ne state
cercando uno andate con questo è questa
collana è stupenda particolare frase
club stupenda scusate se dico
semplicemente stupendo ma non so che
cos'altro dirvi infine qui abbiamo il
necronomicon io sono un amante del mondo
di lovecraft storia infinita erice
inizio bellissimo che è bellissima
aperti in mezzo alla rottura dico io
devastante altri bill inglese che adesso
non riesco a cogliere e che quindi forse
nascondono dei libri stupendi ma che non
vi racconterò qui altri giochi da tavolo
evidente cosa farvi vedere dixit
sicuramente risiko un must al quale non
so giocare e zombie site gioco
cooperativo meraviglioso aggiungo anche
squillo di manuel castro per farsi una
risata di gioco per un po a noi a questo
qui è un pochino un triste perché ci
stanno prova se della società contratti
preferito vedere questo perché si chiama
panalità sono molte e compagnia varia
casa progetti insomma poi utile a là
sopra figlio prendere assolutamente per
fare i pignoli
in un periodo di prepotente
omosessualità mi ero dato al taglio e
cucito quindi mi sono preso tutti quanti
libri bellissimi su come progettare
cartamodelli per fare delle alterazioni
e non lo so modellare tessuto manco
fossi armani manuale di cucito a draping
giustamente non si sa mai avessi voluto
farmi una gonna per andare fare non lo
so una red carpet questo che cos'è
questo è un vecchio quaderno o ragazzi
questo questo bando qui ci stanno
no vabbè questo vi fa capire quanto sono
nerd non dovrei farlo vedere non
nascondo qui io ho trascrissi tutti
incantesimo nei dvd r troppo a quello
che facevano come venivano pronunciati
un social game on line su quante sun che
non expedit plus florence 60 che sfiga
angolo delle sceneggiature tutti i film
e quello è preso parte teatro cinema
tutto quello che è stato il tempo li
conservo non so per quanto ancora lo
spazio per loro forse li porterò in
studio prima o poi ma non ne sono
riuscite a liberare ci tengo tantissimo
c'è anche freaks se non sbaglio è quello
lì a tempo perso invertito i due
scaffali scendiamo qui che cosa abbiamo
in cassa che prosegue sotto parlava di
rumiko takahashi questo qui è un campo
la loro capolavoro abbiamo sailor moon
ragazzi extra cosa di niente serve
aggiungere altro
non credo e chavez anche qui le clamp
ceniamo giu e arriviamo nella zona un
pochino la fattucchiera io ho la fissa
per i tarocchi li colleziona è l'unica
cosa che continua a collezionare un
tempo collezionano buffi le carte trovo
meravigliosa devono essere particolari
ovviamente dovrebbe le illustrazioni e
sono pieno non vi leggono di uso un
amico e shirley perché è li trovo belli
da vedere e infine
buona paolo fox astrologia c'è stato
però il come ero preso con l'astrologia
e mi sono comprato tutti sti libri
niente ne sono studiate ed allora
insieme in realtà le letture della mano
e dei tarocchi faccio delle letture
mostra lì per la modica cifra di 170
euro
guardate fogli bianchi per una stampante
che non ho più e infine un reparto nel
quale tengo la mia videocamera
non vedo l'ora di avere un ufficio per
poter svuotare un pochino di questa roba
qui dice di cro fa insomma vi è questo
qui è la mia libreria maggiore
velocissimo vi faccio vedere anche le
altre
così giusto per pianoforte o di libri
della setta dei libri la7 dei libri ha
trovate su instagram è il mio club del
libro digitale insieme un mio amico
marco è un club che teniamo digitalmente
e dal vivo seguitelo su instagram
fratelli protagonisti al marco così
ripetiamolo e poi qui ci stanno dei
libri in realtà un po a caso come
mandato ki moon valori e mondadori sono
curioso di leggerli vi abbiamo una zona
che è assolutamente a cavolo a parte di
dostoevskij che è l'edizione dei
minorenni ma riesco a leggere tantissimo
dal videocamera scusate questo è un
altra zona un pochino buttare ametista
questo dal cotone stato regalato al
gruppo di td di oliver twist saviano la
casta e poi qua ho la fortuna che non
sia con gli amichetti che scrivono
scrivere mi mandano i loro lavori e sono
tutti quanti libri con dediche
io mi dico non servono sia perché mi
piace poter conservare i libri
soprattutto dei miei amici ma se perché
logo speciale il fatto di averli anche
dedicati dall'autore mi sta esplodendo
questo scaffali devo trovare un modo per
riuscire a espanderlo e dargli anche
maggiore importanza
qua sotto la mia parte angeli e demoni
io ho odiato deve argento shadowhunters
mi è piaciuto poi ha fatto schifo alla
fine e ho odiato il cannocchiale d'ambra
ragazzi la bussola d'oro parte bene ma
diventa una rottura dico io filo
bibliche hanno fatta male che qua sotto
lo sappiamo
tutta roba che purtroppo non mi ha fatto
impazzire generale tranne forse lingue
elfi che quando volevo imparare a
parlare come leggo nas che altro abbiamo
indagine su gesù che si sarebbe recato a
me famiglia
no la littizzetto stupenda non è che il
mondo emerso non fanno scusatemi george
martin il trani spade abbiamo un pochino
di roba questo è un angoletto magico e
seconda foto che mi terrò per sempre
stavamo girando fuori cervelli e siamo
insieme a luca andrea paolo frank e poi
ci sono io è una foto che mi ricorda un
momento molto molto bello è in una foto
che nasconde anche dei libri e non credo
di aver letto tra queste c'è anche il
mio così giusto per citarne uno
leggi bene a loro questo qui è un libro
che mi mandò una ragazza no non è questo
c'era uno di questi libri che hanno
pianto appunti di una ragazza dove non
c'è qualche parte estrema non l'abbia
vista e infine qua ci sta il presepe che
mi ha regalato nascosto mia zia non sono
particolarmente religioso c'è la bibbia
c'è il nuovo testamento parlare scrivere
senza errori è un pochino diciamo una
zona che non sono abbastanza blasfemo da
eliminare ma che comunque non tengono in
primissima fila
detto questo anche sopra un comodino
mediamente pieno di libri che sono tutte
le cose che mi devo leggere che me ne
metto lì in modo che appena finisco uno
mi rimetto in libreria negli spazi vuoti
e poi vado a leggere quello sotto
aggiungo anche un'altra cosa io sono un
avido lettore sia di libri cartacei che
di chi devo esser sincero io ho un
kindle races
non pensavo che mi sarei mai innamorato
così tanto di uno strumento diverso dal
pivot il white che purtroppo mi si ruppe
un qualche anno fa tra questo e il
cartaceo tipo un po di libri mi piace
tanto quando tempo poterlo passare a
leggere trovo ancora che la lettura e la
scrittura siano quelle forme d'arte che
ti permettono vera
niente a costo zero di creare dei mondi
che nemmeno i migliori effetti speciali
del cinema riusciranno a creare to
sfrutti denaro e gli investimenti nella
tua immaginazione e dell'immaginazione
del lettore o della prima generazione di
quella dello scrittore e rimane una
forma di racconto che per me è
preziosissima leggere un libro è come
vivere un'altra vita è più vita abbiamo
la possibilità di vivere e più secondo
me riusciamo a convergere gli aspetti
migliori degli inserimenti di queste
nella nostra e quindi si ammetto anche
di utilizzare lui e di avere una
libreria abbastanza piena anche qua
dentro spesso compro i libri che mi sono
piaciuti più in cartaceo anche ed
aggiungo lì ma ultimamente sto cercando
di evitare perché oggi alla libreria
bella bella zeppa dovrò comprare una
casa nuova carne a regalare con una
libreria tipo quelle della bella e la
bestia
spero di non avervi ammorbato ragazzi
non so se questo video vi possa tornare
utile o anche solo ribassata essere
stato di aiuto in qualche modo io però
vorrei farvi una richiesta 1 se potete
carni su instagram guglielmo scilla
pagarmi in alcune foto delle vostre
librerie e farmi vedere come sono fatte
perché piace molto nuovo vederle anche
prendere delle idee su come posizionare
i libri o su come incastrarli con anche
degli oggetti che come avete visto ciò
pochino sparse in giro mi ha fatto
vedere una cosa per me lo faccio vedere
subito alla fine e se potete farmi delle
foto dei vostri libri preferiti dicendo
neanche per che cosa vi piace di questi
che magari li utilizzerò per la scelta
dei libri in visto che a volte le idee
non ci stanno e non so quale proporre
detto ciò iscriviti da questo canale
mettetevi un bel pollice in su per il
niente ci vediamo domenica con un cucina
buttata
però adesso mi devo far vedere una cosa
prima vi ho parlato ieri poker ma non vi
ho fatto vedere la mia bacchetta un
regalo non è stato factor dove c'era il
biglietto
la lettera che poi questo reato la mano
ma io la mia amica è un pochino tipo
all'altare ci sta allaccio ancora felix
felicissimo e caramelle tutti questi più
la blow poli il boccino e questo
solamente per ricordarvi a tutti quanti
che tendenzialmente anstey lartin jenny
from the block la vita può darti tante
soddisfazione ma se sei facciamo rimarrà
tale